中大膽周报
公开版277集
好大盘从破4万点一路反攻
一路攻攻攻攻攻到了4万6千点的附近
但是呢在周五出现了一些些的压力
那我们也有看到这几天有一些好的现象
例如说外资有回来买
所以对于最新的一个礼拜布局
到底中总怎么看呢
好的这一波的
你也有看到这几天有一些好的现象
例如说外资有回来买
所以对于最新的一个礼拜布局
到底钟总怎么看呢?
好的
这一波的股票市场上的指数
有来到我先前所预估的四万五千点左右
是
那我四万五千点
我都会建议投资人就把持股降低到五成左右
那很多人就会觉得说
钟总这一波好像你看不太准
坦白讲我看的准或准不准
不是那么重要
是最重要的是
我要让你卖在可以卖的位置去
相对好的位置
举个例子
我们上次建议大家在前一波的时候
建议大家46,500点以上就卖
那后来我就最高48,000
那没有人可以卖到最高像48,000这个位置
通常这一波也曾经跌破4万点
那我的建议通常就在41,000左右
你就开始更要积极的去买
所以呢
我偶尔就是抓那个比较
你可以适当的卖出
也可以适当的买进
那45,000点
坦白想现在正在整数关卡这部分
做整理的部分
虽然已经过了
但是我之前有讲过3%的测试理论
所以近期4万5万过
但是要观察一段时间
到底能不能顺利的站稳才最重要
这一次整个大盘的走势能够超乎我的预期
或是市场很多人的预期
最主要就是双I效应
就是包括CPI还有包括MSCI
坦白想这两个部分
我个人觉得是CPI的部分倒还好
是因为我们之前应该有
大家应该预期应该会不会升息
那么快
MICS之前大家认为说应该会降
比较惊讶三升
而且它这次纳入的个股
还有包括中小型个股也算是蛮多的
我觉得这个部分是比较跌破市场上的眼镜
但原本上如果你45,000卖
跟你后面那到46,000
其实那1000点左右
你是不是會抱得相對的不是那麼安心
所以我個人認為說
4萬5賣掉沒關係
反正我們之前跟各位提到過
你手中還有五成
你不見得一定要把手中的部位壓到非常高
所以呢
如果是這樣的話
那投資朋友你就按照我們現時的模式
我還是一樣
4萬5千點之附近
你就把它持股降低到五成左右
因為有投資朋友在問我這件事情
我會不會去調整我的看法
不會
因為各位投資朋友
现在是8月中
半个月前
你的紧张钥匙
叫你不要卖
也是我在叫你不要卖
现在叫你卖
也是我叫你卖
奇怪投资朋友
你住在一个国家
你半个月前跟半个月后
台湾还有全世界
不都是一样吗
没有变啊
变的是什么
你原本变得很悲观
你现在变得很乐观
这位置我还是小心提醒投资朋友
就是在这边
不要做一个追涨动作为什么呢各位去看一下过去从今年以来连漲四天以上大概有六次然後呢我們過去發現除了美意戰爭
開戰後的四月份
就從四月份
五月份那段時間
曾經有連漲之後
他可以連續
往上攻來到
這個
四萬點以上
這個位置
除了這次以外
你會發現
從今年以來
連續漲
四天以上的
最後面
有一個情況
一定会拉回到月线
我们来看一下
像今年在2月份的时候
你从图上可以看到
连长了4天之后
甚至更多天
那粉红色线叫月线
你会发现后来都回到
这个粉红色线就是月线的位置
然后呢
5月份我这边有特别框出来也是一样
你会发现连长4天之后
后面都来碰到月线
5、6、7、8都一样都有情况
换句话说现在已经连长了4天之后
那禮拜五真的四天就踩插車
然後就有點在46,500點這附近之前
先踩插車
我個人認為說如果你真要買
那目前的月限大概在43,600點左右
換句話說你賣45,000
我們不認為你會吃虧
因為你只要相信一句話
這個大盤有高有低
高的時候你把它四樣賣掉
低的時候你再把它做買進
相對這個制裁能夠持贏保態
是
投資朋友可能會想說
难道你不积极的把要不会买
买一买吗
各位有没有发现
如果你在4万点4万1买进的话
你现在随便买哪一档股票应该都赚钱
但是如果你在4万5或4万6以上买的
你现在买或许会有赚钱
但是那个可能要手脚快
你就不会像4万1或4万点那时候买
那么轻松之大
你现在把所有的K线调出来看
基本上你只要那个4万1附近你买的时候
你会发现基本上随便买5%10%都一定有
甚至20%30%也会有
所以如果你懂我所讲的
你只要留有现金在
你随时等待这个低档机会再做进场就可以了
那我们来看一下投信过4万4以上
买超的部位变小
那当然礼拜五稍微有增加到77亿
但是也还有也没有变得非常多
我个人认为说量人不增
那久日KT已经进入到超买区
那我个人认为说就是我刚才讲的持股到五成
那如果来到4万6
我不是叫你不要卖
甚至要降低到剩下四成
那这部分来讲就观察46350
这个45000点的3%的上缘的位置
我想这个部分我还是秉持我先前的看法
长线的部分呢
因为这次的双I效应
你可以提升到42000
也就是说4000点要再建
很难再建到了
那这边位置来讲的话
外置最近转大幅的买超
但是空单没有发现到
没有明显的下降
虽然礼拜五还有降
但是那个部分降个1000多口
其实坦白讲
他現在目前的口味口數還有將近有8萬多口
還是算是非常高
所以我個人比較偏向是短多的這種效應
那口口性的高檔買超變小
我認為說現階段你還是等到穩健區再做買進
除非這個量一直放大那外資持續願意大量做買進那可能就會改变我们先前的看法好,等到回到43,000稳健去的时候你再把它加码到6成到8成
然后回到超级稳健
你的持股比重再提高到8到9成
我的看法还是这样
不会因为今天大涨
或来到45,000以上
我会改变我的想法
同样的之前来到41,000
40,000点的时候
我也不会改变我的看法
我都一样不会去改变
因为企业获利数字就差不多
提醒大家一下
如果来到4万6的话
就表示今年的涨幅就是差不多六成
六成不能说太多
但是呢
如果能够拉回一些的话
可能汇局会走得更稳健
另外一个部分也是
到少数人不会去看的部分
今年的第二季尾巴之后
7月份会出现大底
最主要是各位去看一下
第二季的成交量
季的成交量是74.45兆
比今年的第一季44.35兆
大幅增加快七成
从图上你可以发现到
今年的第二季之前
也就是说今年的第一季跟去年的第四季
这样的量你会发现很温和的增加
但到了今年第二季的时候
成交量明显很暴增
那暴增通常就是下一季
它走势就会比较辛苦
换句话说这一次很多人就会认为说
48000点马上回来过
我跟各位讲不用想太多
不用想太多
就是不会一次过
因为毕竟你要看那种成交量
这种情况就像在21年的时候
你发现了
81年的第二季大概29兆
然后比第一季的19兆
大概增加56%
但你发现在先前的时候
也是量很温和增加
大盘就可以实际上新高
换句话说现在走势
个人认为会比较像
21年第一季之后
这种高档在盘准部分
所以我认为说
以现这一段第二季
如果到8月中的收盘价来讲
目前是呈现一个
算是修正不是很大
那我们上次也提到过8月份的指数
不太可能会把7月份的跌幅完全吃下
所以我想你要心要有一个定见
你不要看涨
你就看乐观
看跌悲观
那你永远就在做一个追高杀低的动作
我们再回头来看一个另外一些角度
央行7月份在减发定存单超过740亿
换句话说
他也帮整个市场上的资金
也在注入到1.46兆
那各位发现
央行的定存单
未到期的定存单
在今年1、2、3、4月份的时候相对是比较高
5、6、7来到相对比较低
你有发现好像跟股市的走势好像就完全相反
就是钱就是要流入到股市去
那我们来发现一件事情
就是上礼拜我有看到这则新闻
那我想也跟投资人
还有甚至是我们也比较投资的年轻人来分享就是
你还能不理财吗
各位发现你的薪水是越来越高
那各位发现
你原先在109年的時候
大概42000
拿到目前將近快49000的薪水
好像每年越來越高
但是呢
你也發現
月薪的中位數也越來越高到39000
但是呢
低於平均的月薪的
者位的人數的比
卻從66%創新剛剛來到7成換句話說將近有7成的人領不到平均月薪所以這個部分我想
當然最主要因為是高新竹
拉高了平均的月薪
另外來講就是產業移工
還有部分工時人數增加比較快
造成這種現象
但不論如何
我們可以發現到現象就是
你一定要做理財
否則從109年統計到現在
你要發現經過了將近5、6年的時間
如果你没有去改变你的想法
改变你的策略
你可能永远还是会在
第一平均月薪人数的部分
因为这个大概将近有600万的人
受雇员工的人数是这样子
而这次的这个部分
也反映到一种情况就是
电子零组件加班
还有电脑电子光学的制品
加班的时间
都创下这近47年的同月的最高
那当然要领高薪也有原因
也加班
所以既然是如此的话
那我觉得你要去调整你的策略
也當然不是叫你現在買到
馬上去在軍橋買股票
如果能夠配合我的高低點進出的話
我相信應該會改善你的方式
我們再來看一下
這張圖6月21號261集講到現在
再放一次
因為我每一次會把它更新
現在位置已經快接近到46500點位置
然後已經快接近到超級積極區
所以我期待你更要降低10股比重
你有沒有發現你現在抽心態
做法是不是像越來越積極了
快要超級積極了
上次呢
跌到39,400點的時候
你會發現穩健
然後到39,500點的時候
我第一次用兩倍ETF正數的
然後那叫超級穩健
你有沒有發現
這張圖的文字
我全部都在一兩個月前都已經玩好
所以你現在心態有沒有變得很積極
肯定有很積極
而且呢
如果下禮拜來到46,000點以上
以後變得更超級積極
什么股票都是很强
什么股票都可以买
等到又拉回的时候
什么股票好像又不好
所以我还是建议来回做操作
因为毕竟第三季的行情不是这么走的
好,其实这张表已经连续两集都有放了
我有看到有一些朋友会很担心
会不会一直往上就往上
事实上当然什么事情都有可能性
但周大胆他的路线是很一致的
他希望能够在稳健区跟积极区这一段来做
下面叫超级稳健
有时候不一定会跌得那么深
上面超级积积
他也希望大家不要因为盲目的乐观导致受伤
既然想法是一致的
那认同这份理念的朋友
应该就可以体会到
为什么4万点可以大家买
4万5千点以上
卓亮的做一些解码
不是叫大家出厂
因为理财是非常重要的一件事情
刚刚讲的
平均薪资往上走
可是平均薪资以下的人的占比却变多了
希望大家从定存或是从哪边流到股票市场的钱
是能安稳赚钱的
如果认同这份理念
再来订阅我们的VIP吧
我会把订阅的连结放在留言的第一则
那我们就VIP见吧